if it works it's going to shed some
light on one of the biggest mysteries in
sensory science which is we're going to
see if i can taste fat
right not bacon not cream
fat right uh specifically
this fat
this is linoleic acid this is an omega-6
a polyunsaturated uh fatty acid and
taste researchers who are investigating
this think there are pretty good reasons
why humans should be able to taste fat
so
it's essential to our food supply it's
used by the brain it's used by the
immune system they say there's a good
reason why your body should be able to
pick it out
in its environment right
so
scientists currently divide taste into
five basics or primaries these will look
very familiar to you i'm sure salty
sweet bitter umami also known as savory
and sour
right and these are considered the
building blocks of taste things that you
cannot break apart you cannot subdivide
just the way on the color wheel blue or
red are considered primaries or basics
right a scientist said to me you cannot
subdivide sweet sweetness is a thing
unto itself right
but some of you might remember those of
you who like me went to school in the
last century remember a time when there
was only four
right
so this idea of umami or savory only
made the list in the year 2000. for
people who are still like what is that
it's usually the flavor that's
associated with things very savory
things like parmesan cheese caramelized
onions a slow-cooked tomato paste would
be considered umami
so that's in the united states
this concept was actually stud uh was
actually um
named in 1908 in japan by a scientist
named dr kunai akita who said it is a
fifth taste and it's associated with the
amino acid glutamate right just the way
sugar is associated with sweet salt with
salt he says glutamate is what's
responsible for msg
when this was accepted in the western
world around the year 2000 it kind of
upended the taste research world right
if there were five now why not six one
at seven why not a thousand right
it's kind of like where we are right now
with taste research is the where
astronomy was at the end of the 17th
century when astronomers were like oh
okay jupiter what if there's something
out beyond jupiter right what if our
system is bigger than we thought it was
so fat is championed by dr rick mattis
who's a nutrition scientist at purdue
university and what's weird is there is
actually no list of what you have to do
to be considered a basic taste so he
made one
which people like so here's the basic
ideas first of all has to be a receptor
for it on the tongue there has to be
something that locks with a certain
molecule and they believe there are two
for fatty acid
they're called cd36 and gpr 120.
okay nerves it has to get to the brain
along the right nervous pathway it has
to go along the gustatory nerve so this
is tricky because your mouth also has
nerves in it oops part of me your mouth
also has nerves in it for touch when it
comes to food this is what we call mouth
feel right that things feel creamy or
they feel crunchy or whatever and people
sometimes say why isn't spicy
a basic taste or why isn't cool a basic
taste it's because that's actually touch
it's a feeling it's actually pain in the
case of spiciness
okay has to have a purpose i know i
wrote that in yellow so nobody can see
it uh it has to have a purpose and the
idea is well not not everybody agrees
with it but usually they'll say okay
basic tastes are either attractive or
aversive so the idea with sweet is as
attractive it shows you where the
calories are so you want to eat it and
the idea with umami is that it shows you
where the protein is that's what amino
acids are in so that's good to eat it um
bitter things are usually poisonous
toxic so don't eat it with salt and with
sourness people disagree but they think
it's either a matter of concentration or
satiety in other words you like a little
bit but you don't like a lot or you like
it when you your body needs it and then
you reject it when it's too much
okay must have a physiological reaction
this one's a little bit trickier
so mattis says your body has to do
something in reaction to it with fat a
lot of fats are these giant blocks
called triglycerides
mattis says there is a
salivary enzyme that called lipase that
basically chips free fatty acids off
this big block that's what can lock into
the receptors on your tongue they know
that mice
make this
uh this enzyme and they can taste fat
because when they block it mice stop
preferring the fat
right but do humans have it and so in
his human experience experiments what he
does is he makes people to hard fats
like coconut and soft fats like olive
oil and then he measures how much lipase
they produce so chew the hard fat you
salivate more you get more of this
lipase there that he says is the
physiological reaction
all right here's the thing we care about
can anybody actually sense the darn
thing right and can they can they
actually distinguish it from the other
five that we have so that's why i went
to the museum
[Music]
you